bye
yes sir this proposal was before the
committee last month
and the committee decided to postpone
after a robust uh discussion
the proposal makes changes to the rules
regarding the ignition interlock devices
previously you heard testimony in
regards to the alcohol set point in the
rule which is on page six of the
conditional approval request
public testimony indicated
that there was a concern that the
devices are not set correctly that it
should be set at .025
but the
statute rsa 265 a37
is establishes penalties if someone has
a breath concentration of 0.025 but it
does not require that the device be set
at that level
the department indicated that the .020
is the industry standard and in
conversation with the department it
sounds like
that's pretty much what the industry
does
and that pretty much summarizes uh the
the remaining issue with the proposal
and the department is here to answer any
questions
good morning martin montgomery from the
department of safety
i have also representatives from the dmv
if anybody would like them to step
forward
it was my recollection that last month
when we were here
there was bob blaisdell representing one
of the vendors who had expressed certain
concerns uh two of them he had
my recollection again was that he
withdrew them and the one that was
remaining related to
um new customers having to pass three
since the last meeting we did meet with
uh bob and his
representatives from
the company intoxlock
and i am authorized to represent that um
after our conference call and a
collaborative effort we are all on the
same page bob also stated that they
appreciate the clarity and the ongoing
open door to discuss and work together
on any issues that may arise
as a result we encourage jail card to
move forward with the proposed rules
i think that was one of the issues
issues with regarding the set point
this is not a new requirement
in our current rules that are continued
the set point the alcohol set point was
established at .020
at that time
the model specs were a
1992 version of the
national highway traffic safety
administration which we incorporated by
reference we updated it in this rules
and the model specs
dictate again
their recommendation that the alcohol
set point be 0.020 once again the set
point only stops the vehicle from
starting it it does not register as a
violation to the user
i would also point out
that we do have
a handful
of under 21
in the alcohol ignition interlock
program and
at a 0.020
they're considered driving while
impaired
so a violation under our program at .026
would allow them to start the vehicle in
spite of the fact that
if they're at a .020 it should be a dwi
the other thing i would also bring up is
that
i think there was concern about whether
or not the commissioner had the
authority and i had pointed out to our
rulemaking authority
where the legislature had
authorized the commissioner to set forth
the specs for the devices and certify
those devices that is not
dissimilar to what the legislature has
done with regards to the breathalyzers
that is used out there where the
legislature has delegated to the
commissioner to set forth those devices
so with that i would encourage
the
committee to
um yep the conversation
last time
said that if you set it at zero
uh two zero okay
and
the vehicle won't
start
then you have taken a punitive action
that
is not
included in the legislation and that's
the part that bothers me and i think
bothered some of the other people
uh hearing rules is that
i'm a teetotaler so i'm not going to
worry too much about it for me but if i
go out there and i am not
legally drunk for the statute
and there's no requirement out there for
me
to
do anything
then my vehicle not starting
you know if i blow a an o2o
is not
you know where is the requirement that
you're going to stop my vehicle from
starting at that point that that's the
question
so the the ignition interlock program is
also intended to be a behavior
modification tool and to help those
individuals recognize that even at a
0.020
they might be impaired uh the for for
someone over 21 it's 0.08
the legislature has indicated that
anyone driving over 0.025
the would be a violation of the program
again
the question is
where in statute
either federal or state
do you have the right to stop my vehicle
from starting
if i have an 02
okay
because that's what you've told me is
you're going to stop my vehicle from
starting if i have that and i'm not
legally drunk
so we're in statute
is that covered
at a .03 you're asking
0.024 again it's the model
specifications that we incorporated by
reference
in the
federal register volume 78 number 89
that makes the recommendation that the
device
locked the ignition interlock at 0.020
it does not register it's a violation of
the user
which means in essence it's 0.005
and it's about
you know there are variables weight
food the individual themselves but it's
about a 20-minute delay
again you use the word recommendation i
asked you is it in the statute either
federal or state
and i'm guessing that the answer is no
i would refer back to the legislature
giving the commissioner the authority to
to establish and i'm trying to find it
for you sir
um
the department of safety 265 a 36 roman
numeral 5 shall establish rules pursuant
to 541a for the approval of ignition
interlock devices and for the licensing
of approved interlock service providers
and to that end the department has set
forth what those minimum requirements
are for approved devices to be used in
the state of new hampshire
i don't want to keep this debate up but
further in the statute
the
limit is actually set in there when
certain actions are taken
okay so we've given him permission but
we've also told him that this is where
punitive action starts
and so again i
i have problems over the way that the
this set point is established if the
department wants the set point in
statute
you know fine come to us we'll write the
lsr
but right now i don't see where you have
the authority to put that set point down
as low as you are to stop the vehicle
carol
thank you mr chair i have two two
questions one is what's the
the margin of error on the reading
that's a good question that i don't know
i'm going to defer here to um the cmp
you know
we don't know
yeah thank you because that matters i
mean um i think that that's okay you
don't know that's fine yeah
the other question
if i may mr chair
is that
you just said that if someone is under
the age of 21 and they're
blowing
two to
zero
they're in violation or is that a
current permit
it's a dwi
so right and do you in fact
treat it as such
we are not you just let it shut the car
not start the car
do you know
that's up to law enforcement i mean if
they're but what it does is stop the
driver from driving
for 20 minutes
okay thank you
i would also like to add that you know
one of the comments that we received
during the public comment period from
the vendor
um
was that
most ignition interlock programs have an
alcohol set point at which the device
will prevent a vehicle from being
started and a separate alcohol set point
at which the breath test result passes a
threshold and becomes a violation and i
closed that quote so so we that's where
we
included a definition for the violation
set point as opposed to the alcohol set
point
later
thank you mr chairman so uh i have the i
think we all have the same issue
uh not whether this is a good idea now
whether it's a functioning technology or
anything of that nature but rather
whether it is legally based uh in other
words whether you have the authority or
not now you
made mention a moment ago
of something that um
that i want to explore a little bit
further and that is that
so if under the way that the device
works uh the vehicle won't start if
you're at that level right 0.20 0.02
that's right so the thing is you said
that
there's a time element involved too
so in other words the vehicle won't
start but within
what period of time
it is
i realize it it varies depending on the
size of the person the weight and all
that other kind of stuff there's a lot
of variables here
but to the degree that the person
initially can't start their car and that
may not be punitive per se but you are
depriving the person of uh
the the ability to start their vehicle
even though the statute does not clearly
establish
uh that that is the appropriate level uh
but
the time factor in another couple of
minutes five minutes whatever the the
the body has con has processed the
alcohol and the level would drop right
correct can you can you speak to that
issue
that aspect i am not somebody
um
well
so
my understanding and i i did inquire
from our expert well they're not experts
but people much more knowledgeable than
me in the forensic lab um that
if if it dissipates
0.015
an hour
on average you're talking about a third
to drop down between
let's say 0.025 to 0.020 or 0.020 so
whatever if you're right at 0.020
in order to go down you're you
just figure that .005 is 20 minutes
plus or minus so anything less would be
you know if you are at .020
even in five minutes it's evaporating as
long as you're not consuming anything
that's going to detect any alcohol
whether it's mouthwash
medicine anything like that
thank you
okay absent emotion can we go to the
approval
motion
move to object
motion for objection by maguire ii by
gray
discussion
representative tucker
your vote
i'm going to ask a question
it seems as though the problem is that
there's a
age 18 to 21
and then above so
one law one device is trying to deal
with two different age groups
and that seems to be the root of the
problem
and how how can that be
handled
do we need to
reintroduce the bill
do people need to rethink whether we
should have a separate
non
you know eight
difference between 18 and 21
that apparently
is trying to change behavior with a
younger group
it just doesn't seem as though the
technology of the
device
lends itself to two different
uh
set numbers
so yes i i it seems bigger than just
objecting
that it's a problem with the way the
statue is set up
you're
you're absolutely right that they're
trying to do
two separate enforce two separate limits
with the same device set the same way
and the other problem is that apparently
the industry and
the powers that be not just in this
state
believe that
0.020
in order to shut off their to make sure
the car doesn't start where i'm they're
on the brink of become of being drunk
rather than being actually
impaired
is
some of us are questioning that position
mr chairman
may i ask a question of uh
representative mcguire yes
would the basis for the objection be a
lack of authority for the 0.020
yes
thank you
mr chairman
peter so so
one of the issues here i mean i agree
with senator gray's initial statement
the statute just does not say
that you have the authority to go below
as the device currently operates i don't
have a problem with the device
but the
possible
way we can look at this is what ms
madigliani has been talking about
several times is we have given the
commissioner some authority here with
regard to setting the level and so that
that that made the commission or the
committee may
feel that that that's sufficient
authority to proceed but i am troubled
by the fact that the statute simply does
not authorize the level that the device
is operating at and i don't see anybody
on the board on the committee talking
against that concept
mr chair
i'm just going to point out um what
attorney mo digliani pointed to which
was rsa 265 a5
roman numeral five um f it may be broad
enough um to incorporate this standard
it may not be it says that the um
commit this is uh the uh commissioner's
um rule making authority pursuant to
541a
such other matters as are required to
carry out the provisions of this chapter
relative to alcohol concentration tests
that may be broad enough
you know to support that they have some
authority
on this it may not be it just depends
okay we have a motion
to object to the rule
if you agree to the objection you'll say
yes and if you
oppose
the idea of objecting to the rule you'll
say no
representative tucker yes
representative burstname yes
representative schmidt
reluctantly yes
representative mcguire yes
senator apprentice reluctantly yes
senator gray yes
senator ward yes
the chair votes no
so the objection passes
thank you
oplc
thank you mr chair
so the first item on the agenda is 22 54
which is the opel seas practice and
procedural rules
the staff did have a number of comments
on this rule that were addressed in a
later filed conditional approval request
however on the
final approval
excuse me final proposal there are two
notes to jail card that i just wanted to
mention before i started to address the
conditional approval
the first is on page six it's a note
regarding the
bodies regulated by the oplc
there may need to be some statutory
clarification as the statute only
refers to
or only uses the terms boards councils
or commissions
whereas
four of these are
advisory boards and do not fall into any
of those three categories and one uh
number six the ophthalmic dispensing uh
is not an up any sort of border entity
at all it's more of just an action
of dispensing contact lenses and things
of that nature
the second
note to jail car which is found
later on in the rule
has to do with the oplc's authority to
suspend revoke
or deny an initial license
upon looking at the criteria that's laid
forth in this proposal it seems as
though they are pretty straightforward
such as non-payment of fines not
complying with administrative orders and
therefore
may be
not
a problem under the rules as they are
written now but i did just want to bring
that to jail cars attention
for the conditional approval request
the only
comments staff had
was
some unclear comments regarding the
participation of
individuals telephonically in hearings
the
oplc has proposed some rules on uh
holding remote
or virtual hearings however they say
that in their definitions
this is to be done via electronic means
and only mention
uh electronic meaning platforms and do
not mention anything regarding
telephonic participation but then later
on in the rules um specifically
plc20606b
mentioned
providing
telephone numbers
to participants and then additionally
for preliminary
excuse me pre-hearing conferences
in pl
c 206 17b it specifically says that
those are to be done telephonic
and therefore i think the rules need a
little bit more clarification on when
telephonic is appropriate and when
electronic means are appropriate
and those are the only comments that i
had thank you
questions
oh sorry
we have a motion
oh
yes
i have a question are these meetings
covered by 91a are they required to be
public meetings
thank you for the question
representative lindsay courtney
executive director oplc
uh certainly when you convene a quorum
of a public body that is covered by 91a
um an exemption to that is for
pre-hearing conferences that occur only
with the presiding officer and with the
parties prior to
an actual
adjudication okay does but 91a as of now
does not allow
remote participation
in most cases in most cases it does not
allow remote participation by members of
the public body but it's completely
silent as to members of the public
attending remotely
as well as participants in an
adjudicative hearing it's just the
members of the public body that are
required to be physically present
thank you
motion
peter i have a
question mr chairman so are you
providing remote access for the public
in those
in the case of what you've said
because
if you're not providing for remote
access then
the fact that it could be permitted
under your interpretation which i would
agree with
if you're not providing it then it's
it's meaningless
we do provide it we have been providing
it
since the pandemic our boards meet in
person
physically meet in person at our offices
but we for transparency to the public
have always provided since march of 2020
a zoom link for the public to just watch
what's going on
and we find that particularly in
adjudications where witnesses are out of
state and may be outside of our subpoena
authority that it allows attendance for
for those individuals
follow-up so um
and and is the public aware of this and
are they provide and are they
participating on that basis absolutely
we find greater participation we notice
the public meetings uh with a physical
location but we also
allow members of the public to
to observe via the zoom link and you're
saying that is happening oh yes
absolutely thank you that's important
you're welcome
motion
with
on the condition of the staff comments
yes
oh
motion by schmidt second by gray
discussion
all those in favor all right
opposed
emotion carries
and
6b
yes thank you uh mr chair so this rule
relates specifically to oplc's ability
to set fees for
the boards under its
administration
i would just like to point out
the first comment i have is that um
this committee has
back on november 19 2020 voted that when
reviewing board rules to support the
executive director
of the oplc in possessing sole fee
authority pursuant to rsa 310 a1d 2h1
and rsa310a
1e1 and 2
in this endeavor
the
comments that i have on this particular
rule do notice um where there is
board authority to set fees um
specifically
on page the first being on page
nine
i cite the statute where the board still
has the authority to set the fee but
once again that's just a note for jail
car
so that
if legislative clarification is needed
that can
be easier to address
the other notes that i have regarding
this rule is on page
8 plc
1002.10
this emergency rule has been expired
since march 19 2020. so the committee
may have questions about whether the
agency has been enforcing
that particular rule
and additionally
there is an interim rule that has also
been expired
on
plc 12
1002.35 that interim rule
had also expired on march 21st 2020 so
once again the committee have may have
questions of whether the agency is
enforcing
that particular rule
and the only other
comment
from staff is an unclear comment
on page 9 with regard to table
1002.16 there was just some language in
there regarding
the initial licensing where the
introductory language only discussed
fees so there was a question about why
there was language regarding
initial licensure in that particular
section
questions from the committee
carol
thank you um
i understand that it has been the intent
to give
the oplc the authority to set the fees
however in a couple of cases
the
actual fee is set in statute and the fee
you're proposing to adopt by rule is
different
representative are you referring to the
electrology fees i think
electrology yes there was a statutory
change this session um that went into
effect that eliminated that 110 fee but
i don't i know it hasn't been updated on
the gen court website
okay
that's right we did change that okay
and what have you been doing since since
the dentist's
rules expired
uh nothing we have not been receiving
payment the same is true with respect to
veterinary medicine and with respect to
the pharmacies
thank you
move to prove
motion by gray second by
smith discussion
all those in favor aye aye
opposed
lottery commission
yes sir um this proposal makes changes
to the rules on the employee incentive
program
which provides monetary incentives when
sales staff reach um specific goals
there's a one comment to bring to your
attention and that's on page two of the
proposal
this is because the rule no longer has
actual monetary amounts in the rule
the rule now creates an employee
recognition committee that will review
both the sales goals and the incentive
plans and we'll make changes to both
we had some concerns that not having the
amounts in the rule would not provide
employees with notice
on what the amounts are and we were also
concerned that changes to the goals and
incentives mid-stream
could potentially surprise the sales
employees
not allowing them to reach the new goals
the rule does create
or does require that there be a
salesperson and a sales manager on the
review committee
so um at least they do have some
representation and input
um we do know though that uh while the
statute doesn't affirmatively prevent or
allow the agency to create this review
committee
it does say that the incentive program
shall be implemented through rules so an
argument can be made
that this isn't what's actually
occurring it's
one step removed if you will
the jail car may have some questions
about this and may want to consider
clarifying the statute if they think
that this is
not permissible and the department is
here to answer any questions
tell us who you are and explain
hi
my name is
my name is valerie king with new
hampshire lottery and i'm here with
kelly j
cleland and she is our what is your
exact title chief product and program
manager i oversee all the sales reps the
sales marketing
shipping and programmatic
parts of the agency
do you want to come
so the rule was up here
okay
you got it thank you for clarifying can
you hear me now no okay
so the the rule as it was up um for
review this year we wanted to make sure
that it actually was more inclusive and
that it portrayed the changes that have
happened through the agency over the
past number of years
um scratch tickets are by far our number
one product that we sell
however there are other games that are
of importance that
the sales reps do look at and do
focus on when they are out in the field
with our retailers
and over the past number of years there
have been other games that have been
added
through the legislative process such as
i lottery keno
and other games that are gaining in
popularity so
when we looked at this we wanted to make
sure there were a few things that we
could do and some things that covid
actually brought to mind
with kovid sales rose
fiscal 21 we were 18
higher than normal for scratch ticket
sales
that's huge growth
this past year we actually were negative
in growth compared to the year prior
because the sales were so enormous the
year prior
so the year during covid our sales reps
all received bonus
and
during that time the growth was a lot of
it was outside of what they were
doing at retail it was just a growth of
the the fact that there was lack of
things where people could spend their
money on there was a lot of money spent
on scratch tickets
so
what we started to realize is the bonus
wasn't something that we could
change
um for them and that was apparent this
year when the sales goal was too high
and none of them got bonus
because we
sadly don't have a crystal ball so we
can't tell what's going to happen in the
economy nobody predicted what was going
to happen
so
one year we're way too high with all the
sales reps getting bonus the next year
we're way too low with none of
them what we wanted to do with the sales
reps and they've been part of this
review group
is with them with their insight of
what's happening in the field
be able to create a bonus structure that
more
correctly portrays what's going on
in the economy
so when we do have situations and
certainly it's not something that we
would be looking to change all the time
but when there are
societal impacts outside of our control
we want to also shift as we need to with
their consent
so this group that's created
has myself a sales manager and it says
one sales rep but there are actually
three on the committee so we are all on
the sales team
and then there's our cfo
as well as a commissioner
and our executive director
so with the group of us we're able to
have very different mindsets help create
a bonus structure that's based on our
sales but also what's going on in the
world
so that we can shift if need be
so rather than
bonusing the sales reps strictly on one
product line
we'd like to have the ability to add in
other product lines as they become
available and if they seem reasonable to
bonus on
for instance fastplay is a product line
that you may not be familiar with
because it's largely unseen at retail
well if our sales reps are really
focusing on that we might see some
really great growth
in fact the year before last
we saw over 200 percent growth in this
product line and we think that there's
more to grow there
so with the sales reps having those
really great communications at retail to
focus on this we think that we can see
more
growth there as well as some of the
other games that are not jackpot driven
give me five lucky for life
or looking at how many of their
retailers receive bonus in a certain
year
so we're just looking to be able to look
at this
through a greater lens rather than
honing in on one product line
and looking to also
not set a firm amount but look at what
we have available in the budget to be
able to
offer that so
in the past it was very clear that was a
thousand or two thousand for each
quarter
and then there's an annual bonus well
the annual bonus really was just
reaffirming what had already happened
that year so
with the sales reps we said let's let's
not do that let's just have four
quarters and they were they've been a
part of this whole process to create
this rule and have been
advocating for this change
so if there are any questions i'm happy
to answer questions from the committee
senator greg
i i guess i'd like you to respond
to how
the
statute supports what you're doing
that's
the basic question i believe
so i i could say um senator gray like i
said at the outset um the statute and
rsa 26 or 284 21h
the language there says the lottery
commission may develop and implement an
employee recognition program for
monetary incentives to promote increased
sales
then it goes on to say the incentive
program shall be implemented through
rules adopted by the lottery commission
so like i said earlier there is an
argument to be made that this is one
step removed in that
the agency is implementing but through
an employee
committee right it sounds like a good
idea in that that they have
input from the sales rep and from the
managers
on what those monetary incentives should
be and what the goals are based on
what's occurring on the ground but the
statute does say that the incentive
program shall be implemented through
rules
and
like i said so there's no monetary
amounts
in the rule so you can make that
argument or make the case that it's not
actually being implemented through the
rules
mr chairman i would add that
as
uh kim has said it sounds like a great
idea and it sounds from what the agency
has said that they need flexibility to
change this based on economic conditions
out there
but
i think they need either a statutory
change or a statutory exemption in order
to do that
move to approve with the requirement
that the lottery commission work with
the legislature to
clarify the statute so that this is
explicitly allowed
and a second
motion by mcguire second by bursting
any discussion
all those in favor aye aye aye
any opposed
thank you
thank you thank you
real estate commission
yes sir this proposal makes changes to
the application rules for salespersons
and brokers
a conditional approval request has been
filed which resolves almost all of the
substantive issues
there are
two issues to bring to your attention
um the first one is on page one
and this is um most likely just a a
matter of language tina and i were
talking about it before the meeting
and um it's this um
comment in the middle of the page on
page one
the language here says for principal
broker applicants check either yes or no
to that state following statement
so it just is unclear um the language
just needs to be cleaned up a little bit
um i don't recall what specifically
tina was going to suggest for that
language it sounds like my
recommendation wouldn't quite work with
that i'll go ahead and let tina comment
on that
good morning i'm tina kelly
program specialist at the office of
professional licensure and certification
with that specific comment we would just
reword it
and for principal broker applicants
comma check either yes or no to the
following statement
okay
the
next issue is
on page six and this comment is in
regards to the examination fees
the statute requires that the board set
the fees for the exams
and the fees are on the form
one is in the amount of 155 for the
sales reps
the other is 170 for the brokers and
this is their initial examination for
licensing
but they're not in the rule and
actually
in the initial proposal
the language here stated that the
applicants were to pay what the vendor
established as the fee
and the oplc indicated that it would be
the vendor that would set the fee but
the statute clearly states that the
board needs to set the fee
so the fees are on the form but they're
not the rule so you may have some
questions about why that is and what
actually is occurring here
so it is the the third part the vendor
that um they go directly to the vendor
they pay the whatever fee is they charge
they fill out the application they take
the exam then everything's provided
to oplc
um
i have spoken with the board's
administrator and once these rules if if
they are to pass
the fee will be taken right off the form
and we only link to the form
so that
the the person who wants to take the
exam knows where the form is
um and as far as there there's no way to
to
put into rule what the exam company
would charge
so
there needs to be a statutory change
because also you couldn't you can't
dictate um the fees for continuing
education that's outside vendors they
set their own fees so there's a lot of
changes in this one
portion of statute that will need to be
changed
yes
thank you
i notice that the fiscal note
says that the fees are going to be
substantially increased
and i'm wondering what the justification
for that is
are you referring to the fees for
the licensure itself as opposed to the
examination obviously yes
i understand the issue
so i mean with the chair's permission
i'm happy to provide the committee with
a spreadsheet of where the boards are at
percentage-wise
thank you that's what i was looking for
so you'll see on the second page with
respect to the real estate commission
you'll see in the right hand column that
the boards are really all over the place
uh in terms of that
the ratio between expenses and income
which was
it's been a ongoing uh long-standing
project that we've been trying to work
on to
get the fees where they need to be but
i'm sure the committee is well aware as
to why we have not been able to
accomplish that right now
the real estate commission
is presently at 95 percent
the um which obviously is 100 and it's
not between 100 and 125
so the average cost uh
per license
125 percent of cost per license is 86
and 32 cents
um so essentially when we ran the
numbers back in september which we
provided this information to the boards
um and uh a proposed fee adjustment and
you'll you'll notice on the 1002s that
the committee just reviewed the dental
fees actually go down
um 155 is the average cost
per license for two years and that's
precisely what
the real estate
commission is recommending in this
proposal
real estate has essentially been
subsidizing
the cost of the license with the cost of
the
examinations the examinations have been
much higher
so essentially they've been paying i
think it was 155 and 170 for
examinations but we are receiving a
windfall because that's not the actual
cost of the examinations so by moving
the examinations directly to the vendor
eliminating the requirement that the
person that the applicant come to us
first wait for us to certify that
they're authorized to test and then go
take the test which takes time
we would have lost revenue obviously
which requires the real estate
commission to adjust their fees to
account for that lost revenue
thank you
so i i've never seen a document like
this before have you been doing this for
a while lindsey
that document um i put together last
september and i have revised it
on occasion um
but
yes
because this is i mean you have to know
what's going on and i i this is the kind
of thing that has to be done so we know
you guys have got to track this and this
makes sense to me
any discussion
all those in favor
opposed
the motion carries thank you
department of revenue administration
so i don't know why we have
yes thank you
no
i've not exactly been told
no in their annual report they've
included the
basic costs and the
ratios thank you mr chair
so 9a has to do with the
relative computation of the gross
business profits
tax this
rule is being brought forward due to
some legislative changes that occurred
the first comment um
is in 304 revenue 304.06
e
it is listed as an edit but it really
is more of an unclear comment as the
department has used
may
when talking about
the commissioner's action in
response to whether or not further
adjustments of a formula are needed when
that really should be shall is it's not
in compliance with the
manual as is required by rsa 541
a8
and the department is here um in case
the commission has a committee has
questions for the department
mr chairman
i would add to rebecca's comment that
if the commission if the commissioner is
not going to do this
require this in every instance then they
need criteria in other words shall if or
shall unless
good morning good morning my name is
king ming wong tax policy council of the
department of revenue
um the
specific language that is being referred
to is on rev rule 304
panel 6e
and that language is specifically
referencing the rsa 77-83
roman 2.
and in that
rsa itself
the language that's used
the authority has given to the
commissioner is also a may authority
and anything further we fear might be
just overstepping the language that's
provided in the statute
and if i may respond to that the reason
that the manual and why we require shall
be used with regard to department action
is
even though the statutes give the
discretionary authority to the agency if
the agency determines that they want to
use that discretionary authority they
have to do so consistently
and therefore put it in rules so that
the public is aware
which is why rules otherwise it would
potentially result in oral rule making
uh which is in violation of rsa 541a
iii
it is also i just want to point out that
it is also applied consistently in terms
of when when there is an audit and uh if
the department determines that there is
a need to all the
the uh
the uh the method that's being used by
the taxpayers does not fairly represent
the activities in new hampshire the
apportionment in new hampshire
then we would the department would
recommend a change in that um of course
in any time that the department
changes the uh the method that's being
used by the taxpayer
we the department will always have to
substantiate that to the taxpayer it's
not that the department will
require a change and and not justify
that because we will still be held
accountable to the taxpayer and if the
taxpayer does not agree um there is also
a method to for there's a there's a as
an approach for the taxpayer to object
to to the uh
to the department's
suggestions for the change for the
appropriation methodology and it can go
all the way up to
the judicial review
if there is a
procedure in place where it's being
applied consistently then that should be
able to be codified in rules if there
already is a process in place then being
able to put that in rules
should be fairly easy
and with regard to the other situations
as attorney morel has pointed out uh you
can always use the shall
if or shall unless to kind of
give those kind of situations where the
rule uh the commissioner shall have uh
the ability to
adjust from
fixing the formula i believe in my
conversations with attorney wong
he had brought up some sort of
negotiations that sometimes can occur or
some settlements that may occur once
again if that's a process that's being
used by the department it should be able
to be
codified in rules
yeah it's um
we are following the language in the
statute
and um
anything further
it is it is standard practice that's
being done in the past that um
that we've been following and it's not
like this is not a new change that we're
adopting for this particular uh
rule rule adoption
this rule
this language in this rule has been
here um
like
probably
probably since 1999 because that's when
the statute was established
with this particular language and that
has also
be that would be the time when the uh
the rule language was established and
approved by jail car at that time
go ahead
yes thank you i'd like to point out that
we have become more aware of this issue
since 1999
and
we want to see what criteria and what
processes you use
when you are making these adjustments
so does that mean the the um
so the process would be the audit
process because the commissioner will
never
know of the um
of the the methodology that's being used
by the taxpayer until
unless it's audited that is audit i mean
that's that's i think that's a fair
statement
so um i'm not sure so so you're
in this section you're only talking
about
what happens after an audit and not
general rule filing general tax filing
it is it will be
the authority is given for the general
tax filing too but for the commissioner
to actually
suggest a methodology for the
apportionment that the commissioner
needs to be aware of the methodology
that's being used by the taxpayer and
in
in most instances that would be during
an audit
for the audit process
what could potentially occur is if it's
codified and codified in other rules the
audit process may be referencing those
rules here
as how the commissioner would determine
whether
an adjustment formula is needed but once
again if an adjustment to the formula is
necessary once again it needs to be
codified codified in the rules that
how
that would occur
mr chairman
the first line of e says if further
adjustments to the formula are necessary
to accurately reflect the business
organization's business activity in new
hampshire
well that seems to be the criteria right
there if that occurs then either the
business organization
needs to petition
the department or the commissioner has
to require
modification so
so i'm not certain why it couldn't just
be shell simply substitute the word
shell
the other concern that we also have is
that
during audit there are times when the
audit is resolved through a settlement
and um and when that happens
what the if the language is shell would
the commissioner be still
um held to this language of this rule
and not the statute this is the language
in the rule
to
to not be able to bind the hands of the
commissioner and not be able to move
forward and
administer
once again in that situation
using
potentially or the commissioner shall
require modifications under rsa
77a32 unless
negotiations
result in a settlement to correct the
formula or correct the miscalculation
something along those lines
to allow um for those situations
i would also put forward if we include
if we change the word to from made to
shell in the rule here
and so all the commissioner shall
require modification under rsa 7783
roman 2 and then when the taxpayer
refers back to the rsa itself saying
that it's a may requirement so does that
mean that okay yes the commissioner
shall
have the discretion that's allowed in
the rsa
because if we change it to shell
um
it's
this commission shall follow the statute
in rsa 77832 at which the statute says
that the commissioner may then
um
make the change would that be
satisfactory
i i'm sorry can can you repeat that
proposed language again so if we if the
language from in the rule is changed
from made to shell so the commissioner
shall require modification under 77832
and then when that cross-reference to
the language there is may so therefore
this the statute still requires a may so
the commissioner will therefore
abiding by
77832 has that discretion would that be
satisfactory
once again i don't think so because the
statute when the statute uses made gives
the agency the discretion of whether or
not they want to use that authority but
once the agency commits to using that
authority then they have to use it
consistently and have it codified in the
rules on how they're going to use it um
yes i i agree that that the uh as you
say that the statute gives that
discretion to the commissioner so
i mean that is essentially what we're
referring to right now is that statute
language
on this point i guess we're not going to
agree
mr chair i i believe that
the may in the statute is
you know when we do this rule that
so that we can be consistent that
codifying whatever the commissioner's
desire is for
the may
be put in the rule
and
you know putting the exceptions in there
certainly tightening up a lot of the
objections that we get on the rules
committee is that
the things that we're approving in the
rules aren't in the statute and things
change
i would like to see since this is on
august 26th i would like to see this go
back and the staff work with the
department and come back to us with
something that both of them can agree
with
because it doesn't appear that we're
getting anywhere today thank you
may i respond
um
i understand senator gray's point but
there has been a lot of back and forth
between the agency and staff and i think
we're just at an impasse
but i
i don't know if rebecca wants to chime
in on that
um i would agree we had this
conversation
prior to this committee meeting where
the agency took the same position
and we've had this discussion that we
just had in front of the committee um so
i don't believe that
unless the agency is willing to change
that and work with that um that we are
just at an impasse at this point
how often does an impasse go to
to a judicial solution
is this a pretty common practice with
the department it depends on the uh it
depends on the taxpayers happen it
depends on the taxpayer how often does
this happen
i i don't know i don't have that
information
the taxpayer may not bring it all the
way up to judicial review
okay so we'll postpone this until next
month
9b
so 2022
86 once again has been brought forth due
to some changes
some legislative changes this one
specifically in the meals and rental tax
rates
the
comments from staff
have to do first
with the
fis
not
stating that there was a change
in the tax rate it says that there's no
difference between this rule and the
previous rule however this rule does
reference the new tax rate which is 8.5
percent and the previous rule referenced
the previous tax rate which was nine
percent
and um
not that there's much that can be done
on the fis at this point but just wanted
to bring that to the committee's
attention
the next comment is
with regard to the table that is in the
rule it is not in compliance with the
manuals formatting
it is specifically under
revenue 702.11
a
and so once again
rsa
541a8
does require that the rules comply with
the
manual and the formatting in the manual
so this particular
calculation it's not set up as a table
or illustration and doesn't have its own
rule number um so that's why there is
the unclear comment there
that would just have to be reformatted
um
and then additionally as i stated there
was a comment with regard to the fis
that comment is also reflected in that
table as that's where the tax rate is
identified
so rev rule
702.11 that
table um as it may
there is
essentially an example of a calculation
uh that's where that's the purpose of
that calculation there and that um as an
example it was using an older um
m r tax rate of nine percent
uh we're not attempting to change the
tax rate here with this uh amendment to
this rule we're attempting to change the
example that's being shown and uh the
calculation that was using
the older rate so we're just updating
the uh
the calculation the example to reflect
the current 8.5 percent rate
once again it's just a formatting issue
of not complying with the manual
and
not being
uh
correctly in the rules so um with regard
to the table
the committee has questions regarding it
otherwise i would think that either it
could be a quick conditional approval
just to get it into formatting with the
manual it shouldn't be too much of a
problem
i moved to conditionally approve the
rule with the formatting change
and also with the note that the fists
should
have mentioned that tax rate change
which is due to the
statute and not the rule
any discussion
seeing done all those in favor aye aye
any opposed
and before moving on from this rule
there was just a couple more comments um
with regard to
revenue 705.01
a1 and a2 both reference forms
and it's unclear
about
what these forms are and where one could
find
the first form as that part was deleted
in the rule
um
and additionally oil uh staff did not
receive copies of these forms so we were
unable to review them
yes so we saw uh
the 705.01 was not drafted correctly
appropriately so we have brought with us
your replacement language for that and i
will distribute
9c interest and dividends tax
uh excuse me mr chair we should probably
amend the motion to address whatever
changes are coming around
i mean we're accepting a conditional
approval request
we have a motion to amend the previous
motion
by mcguire second by schmidt
any discussion
all those in favor
i
opposed the motion amendment carries to
the motion
so in my handout is the suggested
replacement language for 705.01
and i believe that the concern was on
a1 and a2
and in a1 the the form meals and rentals
tax license application
that is
an electronic form that's available on
our gtc so gtc is the new uh web portal
that has been established through the
rim system
thank you this is very clear and we've
already approved it
oh welcome okay
uh so um
20 22 87 has to do with the interest and
dividends tax um this particular rule is
before the committee because it's set to
expire in october so it's just a
readoption with some edits
however there were a couple of
notes from staff with regard to
this particular rule as well once again
there is a um
no before i get to that the first note
to jail car is just an explanatory note
it doesn't have to do with the substance
of the rule just simply explaining
the principal concern with the ownership
interest and why that is different
between
rev
uh
901.03 in rev 901.04
moving along uh the the major
comment with this particular rule
the comment can be found on revenues
902.01
however it does
carry throughout the rest of the rule
the agency continues to or throughout
the rule uses the word individual in
person
and seems to
switch
without giving a definition of what an
individual is versus what a person is
and both the new hampshire law and the
federal law both
define an
person and individual differently
for example
the federal law 26
usc section 7701 defines a person as an
individual a trust estate partnership
association company or corporation
and then even within the agency's own
rules revenue 901.06 defines a
corporation as an artificial person
and
revenue 901.016
includes in its definition a part of a
year
definition for a part year resident as a
person but does not use the word
individual
so
it's unclear
what is considered an individual and
what's considered a person throughout
the rules and when it applies to an
individual or when it applies to a
person
um
so i i did some research once again
these are rules that are not
being updated with this current
submission these are older rules
and um i do want to point out that ind
is phasing out and will be repealed in
um
and according to my res my research is
that there is a definition for persons
in the new hampshire statute
and that is in rsa 21 total 9
and it's the the word person may extend
and be applied to bodies corporate and
politics as well as to individuals so
the the the term persons is more more
encompassing as as to individuals there
is a definition it's not um
this is not referenced in the 900 rule
it's something that's in the statute i
can distribute this as well
so if if it is defined in statute and
the agency plans on using that statutory
definition i would just recommend that
it's reference
within the rule just to make that clear
of what a person is but once again it's
still
um
is unclear of what is being considered
as an individual within these rules
individual would be
as an individual um it's
and reference referring to 90201 the the
way that the rev rule is written
how uh in terms of maintaining a home
living quarters um
being present in new hampshire having
family living in new hampshire
so that all that referencing for an
individual is a natural
person
thank you for sharing your research
well
any questions from the committee
and
for my next comments um once again we
have an
instance where the agency is using may
when they should be using shall
regarding an agency action um
and i apologize it is
it's 905.03
a3 yep
this page
it's page
14 of the rule
we're good with changing that
okay
anything else
rebecca yes um and there's one more use
of may it's also found in that same rule
but in section b
that also needs to be changed to shall
yes
and that was all the comments that i had
thank you
and that will require conditional
approval to make those changes
okay
any discussion
a motion please
i'm second senator
motion by grade
second by schmidt
any discussion
all those in favor
any opposed
thank you
other business pharmacy board yes sir so
um this is on here to give the committee
an update
so what you have linked is the
proposal
2021-92 which contained the pharmacy 700
rules
and
we linked that so you could see what it
looked like whenever it came through
on may 20th it was approved
conditionally approved with a
recommendation that the board
work with us to identify any conflicts
due to the removal of certain
requirements
and
and for me to make any kind of
recommendations for um rule making to
address those concerns
um
broadly there were just there were three
areas of concern one was that the
statute requires registration of
pharmacy interns including requirements
for supervision and those had been
removed from the rules
the statute also requires the adoption
of protocols and procedures for
temporary absence of the pharmacist in
charge from the pharmacy and then there
were potentially some problems between
the pharmacy 700s and the pharmacy 300
roles
so subsequent to um
to that recommendation or to that
conditional approval the um the board
has adopted these rules
and um you'll see also linked on the
agenda some testimony from mr stout who
is a former chair of the pharmacy board
expressing concerns specifically about
the um
the lack of language in the rule around
the policies and protocols for the
absence of the pharmac in charge from
the pharmacy
so i've met several times with tina
kelly
on these rules and on these three broad
concerns
and next month i'll be making a formal
recommendation
that the committee do a petition for
rulemaking specifically on
that section that requires some
protocols and procedures for the
temporary absence of the pharmacist
may also include a couple of other areas
but wanted to wait for the board to meet
and they met yesterday
and they formed a subcommittee which i'm
sure tina can talk about and they're
going to be looking at some of the other
areas the deficiencies that that we've
pointed out
and
figure out if they've been addressed in
other rules
or what they plan on doing um to address
those concerns like i said it will come
up in front of the committee next month
and we'll have a um a formal petition
ready for you to to vote on
morning tina kelly office of
professional licensure and certification
i presented all of the the various um
topics to the board yesterday the board
had
created a committee before that
this is going to be one of the things
that they're going to take up at that
rules committee
to go over that i it's it's a very new
committee so i'm not sure when they're
meeting next
but they're going they're going to
address
where all of the items for registration
of pharmacies are included in the rules
and if not how to move forward to get
those things into the rules
um they're going to beef up the adoption
of protocols and procedures for
temporary absence of a pharmacist
and then cleaning up the 300s that
address the 700s and all of that has
changed so i've i've given all that to
the board
to work on and to come back with
how they plan to
proceed okay
thank you thank you
seeing no other business will
cancel the continued meeting
all right
anything else mike
meetings adjourned
you